>> Tucker: HOUSE REPUBLICANS
ONCE AGAIN TRYING TO HAMMER OUT
A DEAL ON IMMIGRATION AHEAD OF
THE FALL ELECTION.
THEY FEEL THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR SOME REASON.
A CURRENT DRAFT FOR PROPOSAL
BEING CONSIDERED BY REPUBLICAN
LEADERS IS PROBABLY BETTER THAN
PRIOR PROPOSALS BUT IT FALLS
SHORT OF WHAT THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON.
IT WOULD TO GIVE AMNESTY TO SOME
DA CA RECIPIENTS, AND ALSO IT
WOULD CREATE MORE MERIT-BASED
LEGAL IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
BUT IT WOULD NOT IN CHAIN
MIGRATION CUT OVER MIGRATION
LEVELS OR CRITICALLY IMPLEMENT
E-VERIFY TO KEEP EMPLOYERS FROM
EMPLOYING ILLEGAL ALIENS.
WHAT TO MAKE OF THIS PLAN
EXACTLY?
LOU DOBBS IS OF COURSE THE HOST
OF LOU DOBBS TONIGHT ON
FOX BUSINESS AND IT MAY BE THE
ONLY OTHER PERSON IN LIFE THAT
HAS FOLLOWED THIS SO CAREFULLY
OVER A DECADE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
IT'S COMPLEX THAT I KNOW YOU CAN
CUT TO THE HEART OF IT.
>> LET'S CUT THROUGH THE
COMPLEXITY BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL,
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN IT.
THERE HAS BEEN NO WRITING OF TAX
AMENDMENTS.
IT'S A PREPOSTEROUS CLOSED ROOM
DEAL, ENTIRELY DRAWN UP BY THE
SPEAKER, WHO IS OWNED LOCK,
STOCK, AND BARREL BY K STREET,
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, THE
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE, THE KOCH
BROTHERS AND WALL STREET.
SO IT WON'T BE IN FAVOR OF
AMERICAN MIDDLE-CLASS AND
AMERICAN WORKING FAMILIES, AND
INDEED, THAT IS HIS HALLMARK FOR
20 YEARS IN THE HOUSE.
HE WORKS FOR K STREET.
>> Tucker: SO WHY THE PUSH TO
GET THIS THROUGH WITHOUT A
DEBATE?
IT SEEMS LIKE THE REPUBLICANS
COULD WIN THIS DEBATE IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE POLLING ON IT,
AND THE REPUBLICANS ARE
BASICALLY ON THE SIDE.
>> Lou: AS YOU HAVE REPORTED,
YOU CAN SLICE AND DICE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS ANYWAY WANT TO COME
AND MORE PEOPLE ARE DISGUSTED
AND APPALLED BY THAT DILATORY US
AND A NEGATIVE IMPACT OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION INTO THIS COUNTRY,
AND THAT IS SIMPLY THE
STRAIGHTFORWARD FACT.
BUT THEY CAN'T EVEN RAISE A
VOICE THAT IS EVEN REMOTELY
COMPARABLE TO THE OWNERSHIP OF
THE ESTABLISHMENT AND GLOBAL
ELITES WHO ARE DEMANDING CHEAP
LABOR.
AND THAT IS STRAIGHTFORWARD.
IT IS YOUR PURPOSE TO BRING MORE
IMMIGRATION INTO THIS COUNTRY
AND TO PRESERVE LOWER WAGES.
JUST AS PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
WAGES RISING, THE MIDDLE CLASS
IS NOW GROWING.
IT WAS STAGNANT AND IT DECLINING
FOR 20 YEARS UNTIL
PRESIDENT TRUMP MOVED INTO THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> Tucker: IS A YOU ARE SAYING
THE CURRENT REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IS WILLING TO IGNORE
THE BASIC LEFTS ON THE LAST
ELECTION AND THE EXPRESSED WILL
OF THE AMERICAN POPULATION IN
ORDER TO SERVE THE INTEREST OF A
VERY SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE TO
PAY THE BILLS.
B6 ABSOLUTELY.
AND RYAN IS A LAME DUCK SPEAKER,
HE WILL ONLY BE IN OFFICE UNTIL
JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR, HE
RESIGNED.
BUT THAT'S ALL THE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE CAN DO IN THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
HE IS NOW IN FRANCHISE WITH THE
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE AND ALSO
WHAT WOULD BE ASSUREDLY A LOSS
OF 50 SEATS IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AS A RESULT OF MOVING
INTO THE AMNESTY OF THIS.
THE PACE WILL NOT STAND FOR THIS
FOR ONE MINUTE, NO MATTER HOW
POPULAR THE PRESIDENT IS.
AND HE IS WILDLY POPULAR.
NO MATTER THE FICTIONS THAT ARE
SPUN UP BY RYAN AND HIS
SO-CALLED LEADERSHIP COUNCIL.
>> Tucker: DO THEY HAVE
POLLSTERS WHO ARE TELLING THEM
THAT POLITICALLY, THIS IS SMART?
>> Lou: NO.
THEY HAVE WELL-PAID STRATEGISTS
TELLING THEM THEY SHOULD RUN ON
THE TAX CUTS, RATHER THAN THE
TRUMP AGENDA, WHICH IS THE TAX
CUTS, DEREGULATION, BALANCING
INTERNATIONAL TRADE, CREATING
JOBS, BRING IT BACK
MANUFACTURING, DEALING WITH ALL
THE IMPORTANT ISSUES IN FOREIGN
POLICY, WHETHER IT IS THE
IMMENSE AND     AN END SUCCESS O
IMMENSE AND     AN END SUCCESS F
IMMENSE AND     AN END SUCCESS T
IMMENSE AND     AN END SUCCESS E
SINGAPORE SUMMIT, WHICH IS JUST
ONE OF A LITANY OF ACHIEVEMENTS
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS IN
UNPRECEDENTED ACHIEVEMENTS.
IT IS ABSOLUTE DISASTER.
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: R
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: I
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: O
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: S
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: R
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: I
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: G